reported cases have declined
significantly
from the peak of the omicron wave in
january of this year
and reported deaths are at their lost
since
march
2020. in many countries
all restrictions have been lifted
and life
looks much like it did
before the pandemic
so is it over
no
it's most certainly
not over
i know
that's not
the message
you want to hear
and it's definitely not the message i
want to deliver it's not over anywhere
until it's over
everywhere
reported cases are increasing in almost
70 countries
in all regions and this is in a world in
which testing rates
have plummeted
and reported deaths are rising
in my continent
the continent with the lost
vaccination coverage
this virus has surprised us at every
turn
a storm that has torn through
communities again and again
and we still can't predict its paths
or its intensity
we lower our guard
at our peril
increasing transmission means
more deaths especially among
unvaccinated and
more
risk of a new variant
emerging
declining testing and sequencing means
we're blinding ourselves to the
evolution
of the virus
more than 6 million coveted 19 days have
been reported to who
but as you know
our new estimates
of excess mortality are much higher
almost
15
million does
as we speak
our colleagues around the world are
responding to outbreaks of ebola in drc
monkey pox and hepatitis of unknown
cause
and complex humanitarian crisis in
afghanistan ethiopia somalia south sudan
the syrian arab republic ukraine
and yemen
we face a formidable convergence of
disease
drought farming
and war fueled by climate change
inequity
and geopolitical rivalry
as you know this health assembly marks
the end of my first term as director
general
i'm humbled
by the executive board's decision
to nominate me for a second term